hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt's ein wunsch rezept von
meinen zuschauern aber auch für moral
und zwar packe ich heute eine
schwedische mandl torte oder die
schwäbische eine schwedische weil die
schwäbische nein hätte wohl gerne ist
eine schwedische torte und zwar ist sie
sogar die zehen frei
die torte besteht aus einzelnen pc böden
mit mandeln und dann kommt da noch so
eine richtig lecker man die creme mit
rein und man braucht wirklich ganz
wenige zutaten die habe ich auch immer
zu hause das heißt die torte kann ich
dir immer backen wann immer du sie
möchte dass er liegt nur ganz wenige
zutaten und sie geht auch total einfach
und ich zeige euch mal ganz schnell
ich habe hier fünf eiweiße eine mit salz
120 gramm zucker und 200 gramm mandeln
die habe ich jetzt bereits selber gemalt
für die creme brauche ich dann
verweigerte 200 milliliter milch es
sachen die zweite liga seine 100 gramm
zucker 150 gramm zimmer waren butter und
ihr könnt dann noch zwei esslöffel man
wie sirup oder einen mantel likör nehmen
das hilft einfach so diesen mann wie
geschmack jetzt stelle ich zuerst mal
die b bilden her
stopp preisfrage zuschauer welches
welche zutat fehlt ein extrakt brauchen
wir nicht heute geht es nur um den mann
der geschmack also zuerst gebe ich jetzt
die eiweiße in die rührschüssel da ist
es jetzt ganz wichtig die rührschüssel
muss fettfrei sein und auch der schnee
bis ganz sauber sein
ansonsten kann man das eiweiß nicht
schön steif schlagen dann gebe ich noch
die prise salz mit dazu und schlag das
jetzt mal statt
und sobald es steif geschlagene es geht
den zucker mit dazu lasser noch mal fünf
minuten rühren
in der zwischenzeit bereitet schon mal
die creme vor dafür gebe ich jetzt die
sahne in einen topf da kommt der mantel
chirurg mit rein und statt zucker muss
der mann geht xerox
ja das hätte nämlich total die man den
geschmack also dadurch schmeckt einfach
nochmal nach wandel
jetzt lasse ich das ganz kurz erhitzen
und früher auch hier schon mal die
eigelbe durch sie kommen nämlich gleich
mit rein und dann entsteht so eine art
pudding
sobald die creme also sobald sich der
zucker in der sahne aufgelöst hat gebe
ich die eigelbe mit rein physischen alte
schwäbisches rezept ein schwedisches
automatische machine ethisches prinzip
der zucker hat sich jetzt aufgelöst
jetzt kommen die eigelbe mit rein
jetzt muss ich so lange erhitzen bis 1
siegt aber es darf all ist kochen
in
den pudding fühle ich jetzt gleich um
und zwar muss es gut abkühlen und damit
keine haut auf der oberfläche bildet
denke ich dir jetzt mit einer frisch
alufolie
jetzt kann ich die mandeln unter die b&c
masse heben
dann müsste auch ganz vorsichtig
arbeiten und es wirklich nur unterheben
und nicht einrühren
was ich ja der unterschiedlichen
unternehmen einrühren er ein wenig mit
der maschine und wenn du deshalb unter
hitzfeld jeher zusammen
durch das fed von den mandeln mit der
nämlich ganz schnell zusammenfallen
die fehlerquelle dann geld das reicht
auch schon jetzt habe ich hier einen
spritzbeutel gerichtet mit großer
lokführer und damit werde ich die zwei
bilden dann auf spritzen
jetzt habe ich hier zwei blatt papier
gerichtet und zwar habe ich in einen
kreis drauf gemalt auf der unterseite
natürlich und der kreis auf 20
zentimeter im durchmesser gucke ich dass
ich das irgendwie durch pausen haben und
spritze jetzt da die zwei kreise voll
mit der winkel palette 30 ihn einfach
noch schön glatt
mit sich die papiere auf dem kuchen rost
und dann werden die teiche jetzt beide
zusammen im umgriff backofen gebacken
bei 175 grad
falls jetzt kein umluft backofen habt
könnte auch einfach ober unterhitze
nehmen und einfach 20 grad mehr als 100
95 grad
und da packen sie zu etwa 25 minuten
nachdem backenzähnen die böden jetzt so
aus und damit sie richtig abkühlt sich
jetzt auf einem kuchengitter und sie die
praxis backpapier ab
während die 2b böden jetzt noch abkühlen
kann ich jetzt schon mal die creme
verbreiten
die creme hier ist etwas abgekühlt also
sie jetzt zimmer waren und die butter
muss jetzt einmal kurz weich berühren
die filme habe ich jetzt einmal kurz
durch gerührt also dies jetzt nicht so
fest wie ein normaler pudding bei einer
buttercreme zum beispiel wenn ihr das
gerne etwas fester mit müsste einfach
zehn gramm und speisestärke dazu geben
dann ist aber nicht mehr glutenfreie
außerdem nimmt meist strecke bis denen
die cremes lassen weise mit zur mutter
die creme ist jetzt fertig und damit ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen den kühlschrank
stellen kann so für etwa zehn minuten
völlig sie um dann habe ich jetzt nicht
diese riesen schlüssel im kühlschrank
und dann geht es auch gleich weiter und
wir sind gleich schon fast fertig mit
der gesamten torte
so erzähle ich die torte zusammensetzen
ich habe meine fertigen tortenböden ich
habe die kalte creme und hier habe ich
noch 100 gramm mandeln blätter die habe
ich bereits in der pfanne ohne fett
gerüstet jetzt habe ich hier eine
tortenplatte jetzt heißen wir beide
drauf die sie mir jetzt nicht gerade
genug dass es die sie mir nicht rund
genug deswegen möchte ich jetzt noch
einen schönen rand schneiden damit die
torte auch hübsch aussieht und habe
jetzt einfach wieder den verstellbaren
tortenring und musste jetzt ein bisschen
kleiner stellen und kann jetzt einmal
drumherum schneiden
es hat man zum einen den effekt dass der
teig eben schon rund wird und zum
anderen hat man einfach diesen harten
rand weg damit jetzt meine taten platte
nicht dreckig wird habe ich jetzt hier
papierstreifen zugeschnitten und klemme
hielt daran fest die später einfach eine
schöne saubere platte
jetzt kommt bereits die füllung dran
einfach so etwa die hälfte der creme
hinein für unschön verstreichen
den zweiten boden setzte ich jetzt
verkehrt herum auf das heißt mit dem
boden nach oben da hab ich nämlich eine
schöne gerade fläche und jetzt kommt
auch die rest creme auf nahrung
und jetzt auch die creme hat eine
richtig schöne gelbe farbe und in
manchen rezepten stand sogar drin was
soll die creme gelb einfärben
aber das braucht man gar nicht wenn man
bio eier benutzt denn die sind immer
schön gelb also richtig schön als hätte
ich farbe tritt jetzt bestreite ich die
torte komplett mit der creme
ich hatte die torte ist eine halbe
stunde im kühlschrank jetzt ist sie
schön fest und jetzt kann ich dir
jemanden darauf streuen und dann wird
richtig schön drauf streuen und dann ein
bisschen antreten
ich weiß auch warum das keine
schwäbische vater ist weil man dies so
teuer ist niemals schwabe machen diesen
wahnsinn
deswegen startet ist flach als schwabe
die ruhig machen ich glaube wenn ich mir
nicht machen kaufen müsste dann werde
ich ziemlich flach liegt hatte also ich
fand man mangels in dieser extrem
letztes jahr waren sie hassen das
haselnüsse die juden sich immer
abwechseln nächstens wieder geraten
das hat aber mit den ernten zu tun
selbst daran dass die türken ja da gab
es eine plage oder sowas
jetzt können wir die torte anschneiden
ich glaube frau jetzt schon drauf jetzt
auch richtig schön weich also die böden
waren ja freuen noch etwas knusprig sag
ich mal außen aber jetzt durch die
wartezeit im kühlschrank schön reich
schön durchgezogen musste die lecker aus
ich finde es sieht aus wie gemalt oder
richtig schön es doch sehr viel
schneller -bitte die jedoch relativ
schnell richtig schnell
man brauche wirklich sehr wenige zu
tragen und sie ist sehr einfach und was
sie nicht so gut gefällt probiere ich
sehr
es macht richtig schön ist eine richtig
leckere torte mit abstand wird ich muss
über mich sagen es kommt mir der
schneekoppe mit der kaffee trotzdem
gehört jetzt zu den drei besten wirklich
geniale hat jetzt auch zu meiner
lieblingsorte sich die beste sicht gut
und vor allem keinen vergleich zur der
gekauften version
ja weil ich die kaufte version die gibt
es ja auch im supermarkt zu kaufen im
tiefkühlfach
und dies hat sehr trocken also ich finde
immer ich habe schon einmal probiert und
ich von seinem friedrich mit sicherheit
eine der besten schwäbischen ehemalige
schwedische alter schwede wenn ihr das
rezept nach machen wollt dann geht
einfach auf meinem blog auf sase -
blog.de dort steht nochmals genaue
rezept vor allem finde ich so toll das
ist einfach meine glutenfreie torte ist
ja kein mädel mit drin wie man richtig
also ich freue mich wenn ihr die torte
nach macht und wenn wir uns dann ein
foto auf facebook oder verschickt bis
zum nächsten mal und viel spaß
super wäre dies auch kund ich schneide
mir sorgen bestimmt